en esta oportunidad los dos candidatos
podrán hacerse preguntas entre sí que
podemos esperar
hola me gusta estar con ustedes bueno
realmente es un punto icónico realmente
no tenemos hemos tenido un debate por
más de 30 años en el país en una segunda
vuelta y esto realmente según los
expertos va a marcar un antes y un
después de la campaña presidencial al
parecer está detrás de una serie de
votaciones que en la primera vuelta se
marcaron por candidatos de otra forma de
una nada digamos una nueva generación de
políticos y que no pudieron captar los
ahorita contendientes y que eran otra
forma está detrás la estrategia está de
captar justamente estas nuevas
audiencias creo que la ventaja poco está
hacia atrás a gradas porque es una
figura que es realmente joven nueva más
allá de que tiene detrás el legado del
correísmo y por otro lado guillermo
lazos que bueno representa bien en 10
años y haciendo un postulado para la
presidencia elección presidencial que
algo otra forma también quiere un poco
puede mostrar algún tipo de los brillos
de la política ecuatoriana creo que hay
mucha expectativa en el país por este
tipo de debate porque realmente creo que
va a marcar digamos como lo dije un
antes y un después de la campaña a eso
iba a danielle definir a este debate el
rumbo que tomará el balotaje en ecuador
aparece así o sea según las estimaciones
no hay estadísticas todavía que está
mostrado está publicado encuestas sobre
todo serias solamente en ciertas
cuestiones bastante un poco poco
rigurosas digamos no se puede mostrar
tener una tendencia favorable a ser un
candidato no se dice que hay un empate
técnico entre los dos buenos autores
está por verse pero es italia si hay un
gran porcentaje se destina que los 15 20
por ciento de población todavía está
indecisa y justamente esa gente es lo
que en su momento dieron el voto al
candidato que quedó tercero y al cuarto
el candidato ya q pérez y el señor
hervás que de alguna forma son las las
audiencias que están compitiendo en este
momento los dos candidatos que están en
la fase final no daniel muy rápidamente
que tan polarizado está el país a sólo
tres semanas de las elecciones
es sumamente paralizados yo creo que el
ecuador es de los últimos 10 años se ha
marcado justamente puede estar contienda
de lo que es el correísmo anti correísmo
el cual no ha podido descentrar
desmarcarse de ese tipo de digamos de
ambiente político y de alguna reforma
los dos candidatos que un poco llegaron
hasta esta fase final son los que
representan esta digamos de esta esta
forma de hacer política en los últimos
diez años creo que el problema es la
alta polarización que existe hay mucha
incertidumbre mucha expectativa hay
mucha violencia implícita en las redes
sociales que realmente ponen al próximo
gobierno en la espalda paredes por
situaciones que son muy complicadas que
tienen que ver con la pantalla pero
también por la situación económica que
hemos venido arrastrando en los últimos
cuatro años